good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in
people more than they believe in
themselves and my sincere hope is that
if you see in yourself what I see in you
you'll be able to change the planet so
to help you on your journey today's
message is we are all stars over to you
Beyonce I think a star is born a star
absolutely I think I know me I was born
to do what I do it's just too natural
there are certain things that I know no
one taught me no one can teach you it's
just you are and I feel like we all are
stars we all have that you just have to
figure out what that thing is that we're
supposed to be doing in life and I know
that for me to know exactly what I was
born to do at such a young age is why
I've been able to do what I do as well
as I do it because I've been doing it
for a really long time and I'm doing the
right thing so I'm very lucky so I
believe that everybody has Beyonce or
what I like to call Michael Jordan level
talent that's something you have Beyonce
level talent add something you just may
not have discovered it yet and if you
have discovered it you may not be good
enough at it yet and you need to
practice and hone in your skills and put
in the work and what I really encourage
you to do is look at the work that
you're working on right now does it make
you happy are you fulfilled in the work
that you're doing you may not be happy
with the results you may not be happy
because you're a perfectionist and
because you know you can always be
better you may not be happy because
you're not earning the income that you
want to be earning yet you may not be
happy because you're not getting the the
awards or the accolades from people yet
but are you happy with the actual work
are you happy with the progress because
at the start of anything you're gonna
suck you know the start of me making my
youtube channel I sucked I enjoyed
making the
I enjoyed the process I enjoyed getting
in front of the camera and talking to
you guys but I sucked my delivery sucked
my editing sucked you know my SEO
entitles all of that suck that had no
comments I'm from an external
perspective he liked no comments no
views no awards very minimal growth but
I was happy doing what I was doing and I
wanted to get better at it
and so for me that's the key because you
can quickly surpass people who have
years of experience in any field if you
are deeply passionate about it
the person who has the passion and the
excitement and the enjoyment for the
work and joint for the process will
quickly destroy the person who doesn't
really have the enjoyment that has the
years of experience you can learn
anything really quickly think about
anything that you've learned recently
you could pick it up super fast if
you're motivated to do it if it doesn't
feel like work you can learn anything
whether it's a language whether it's a
skill whether it's how to market
yourself if you wanted to learn YouTube
marketing if you wanted to understand
that YouTube algorithm you could pick
that up really quickly you know within a
day you could no more than 99% of the
youtubers out there just by doing
research and so I wouldn't get so caught
up in a lot of industries about you know
the experience level because you can get
there faster if you have that deep
dedicated passion to it but that's the
thing are you happy with the work and
sometimes that's hard to separate
sometimes it's hard to see something
that you are excited by and you love
doing and you're not seeing the results
and you just keep on doing it for me to
make 5,000 videos to keep on making the
content even though you're not seeing
the results and that's why the the
single most important lesson that comes
from all of these videos all these
people that I've research is to follow
your passion do the thing that you're
excited by because if you don't you're
gonna quit you're gonna quit because
it's too hard because there's lots of
competition there's lots of people doing
it it's just too hard to break through
in a lot of these industries unless you
are super passionate or what you're
doing and so you have beyond c-level
talent at something maybe you've
discovered it and if you have then you
just need to continue to work at it even
if you aren't seeing the results to work
at it every day work at it stop putting
it off to tomorrow
stop quitting stop started and stopping
and starting stopping every day you have
to work on it to get better because
Beyonce had the talent but she put in
the work right that's what you need to
do would it be us I'd never discovered
her singing de whatever Beyonce's never
discovered her dancing she would be you
know working that some job at Costco or
Starbucks or McDonald's or some job that
that was not to her level of stardom
that's what most people do most people
are in a job or even starting the
business that is below their
capabilities where you could be a star
at something and instead you're you're
playing way way way below what you're
capable of doing and so she had never
discovered her singing or her dancing
how much worse off would she be but how
much how much worse off would we all be
right like her music her dance has been
a gift to all of us how many of you have
been inspired by a Beyonce song that
moved you that was there for you when
you need it tough times or that
motivated you to go off and do something
great I have a couple of her songs on my
playlist that I love when they come on
and so you're doing a disservice to
yourself and to your community and to
the world that whole if you are not
going in on the finger you could be a
star and you're living a smaller life
than you should be so the question today
today is what are you a star in or
developing star in you could be a star
in leave it down the comments below
I'm curious to see what natural talents
we have in the leaf nation and also if
you are leaving a comment within the
first couple hours of this video going
live you have a chance to win one of two
daily prizes I also want to give a quick
shout out to chow thank you so much for
picking up a cup of my book your one
word I really really appreciate the
support and I hope you're enjoying the
read thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso
Express Oh give me go
when I was in the seventh grade my buddy
moved away to Oregon there was a week
where I went up to go visit him in
Portland flew up there by myself go to
his house and the whole thing was hey
he's gonna be in school on some of these
days this week so you can shadow him to
school or you can hang out until he gets
out of school I shouted him one day and
I was like this is weird I'm gonna stay
at your house and wait but in his room
there were four things that were very
important a stiff little fingers record
there was a all record the dinosaur jr.
record and there was an electric guitar
so what I did was I would play those
three albums on vinyl and I will go over
and pick up this guitar to keep myself
entertained throughout the day for those
three or four days that he would be at
school until he'd come back and we'd
skate at night and do whatever that
changed my life you know changed my life
the adhearing punk rock music and
picking up the guitar or something
clicked where it's almost like there's a
bunch of gasoline on the ground and
someone flicks a cigarette it just
ignites you know it's just it was a
chemical reaction that just flipped on a
switch that nothing could take that
guitar out of my hand from that point
forward
well I better see you with pretty much
madness just to follow your dreams you
know I mean I think a lot of people get
caught up and get sidetracked by what's
happening I'm around them it was cool
people always ignored a gift not
realizing that gift this was gonna take
you out of your poverty take you out of
your situation that gift of the choice
is the ultimate element that God
provided for you to get you out of any
situation or to take you to what
destined for you
you know some people are just great at
certain things but because music but
modeling or film is cool they alienate
what their gifts are just to be a part
of something that is pursued to be
unpersuaded to be cool it's always felt
like you know my methods and message
always has been and is following the
gift that you have put a lot of
emphasizing and concentrate on what you
feel that you're great in because what
you're grading is always gonna be what
pulls you out of the worst situations
that you could ever imagine it put you
in a better situation today your gift
can be anything you can't look at it as
simply running jumping singing and
dancing but I tell you one thing your
gift is the thing that you do the
absolute best with the least amount of
effort for me it was comedy so once you
identified then that's that's the
beginning of it but there's a lot of
work to do even after you identify your
gift you know you can believe you're
something all you want but if you don't
work towards it you just sitting there
it's gonna be empty